ask someone for the evidence of
Classical liberalism or let's say social
liberalism John Stewart Mill himself
could not produce an evidence that his
contemporaries and his
colleagues were satisfied with and he's
the father of social liberalism in the
west now if he couldn't do it and he's
one of the most Brilliant Minds of the
West in the enlightenment period at the
peak of the Enlightenment period I doubt
a Pakistani blind
follower who attends
Lums because because he has the money to
go here and then he's smoking a little
marijuana and going to a party on the
Saturday
night and he attends the lgbtq
community
yes because his master's the white man
have told him to do so I doubt that that
guy can produce something even
equivalent to what John Stewart Mill
could provide he would be liberating
himself if he had just
said I am just following the white man
they have clean streets and tall
buildings they have a higher GDP surely
they must be right I don't have any
evidence for what I believe yet I am
following them because they have cleaner
streets and taller
buildings just be honest and say that's
because of Hollywood I have been
impacted by Netflix and
Hollywood I am impressed by the white
man I voluntarily put myself under
Colonial ideological
subjugation of the white man and the
white woman because let's be honest
feminism wasn't started in
laor don't don't pretend that second
wave feminism came from laor or Karachi
it's not a a female emancipation
emancipation project that has its roots
in the East it is a western knowledge
production and now if you look at for
example Western
feminists compare the amount of time and
energy that they have put into abortion
issues and equal pay issues with the
amount of energy that they have put into
the more fundamental human right of the
right of life for women in Palestine in
Kashmir or weager women or elsewhere
this shows you without a shadow of a
doubt that they don't really care about
you as much as you care about
them oh you the Quran States this you
love them but they don't love
you why do you voluntarily want to be a
pajit no why
the white man is not
impressed he's not impressed nor does he
nor does he care about you if he saw you
the same Pakistani feminists and
LGBT Advocates that attend
lumps if he saw you on the floor dead he
would have as much care and respect for
that image as we have seen he has had
for the images of the Palestinian women
so if this is the reality there is no
need there is no
[Applause]
need there is no need to subjugate
yourself in this
manner without evidence